[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour une
nouvelle édition spéciale sur tv 78 nous
sommes le jeudi 30 avril 2020 c'est le
45e jours de confinement
le point quotidien sur la situation
sanitaire dans le département d'après
les chiffres de santé publique france du
29 avril le coc u19 a causé la mort de 4
125 personnes dans les hôpitaux
yvelinois ce sont dix décès
supplémentaires dans le département du
côté des hospitalisations 7 à la baisse
et 826 personnes atteintes du virus sont
actuellement hospitalisées ce sont 32
patients de moins par rapport à la
veille baisse aussi du côté des patients
en réanimation et un dernier chiffre à
vous donner 1389 c'est le nombre de
retour à domicile
c'est une nouvelle qui devrait soulager
quelques usagers les trains des lignes l
et hu devraient reprendre du service le
4 mai prochain
sauf imprévu majeur c'est ce qu'a
annoncé la sncf
depuis février les deux lignes étaient à
l'arrêt après l'effondrement d'un talus
près de la gare de sèvres-ville d'avray
les travaux n'étant pas terminée les
trains circuleront à vitesse réduite
des blues créé par des bénévoles ce midi
une centaine de ces blues ont été
remises aux équipes soignantes
principalement secteur qu'ovide et
réanimation de l'hôpital mignot au
chesnay derrière ce dont un collectif
blues pour l'hôpital une trentaine de
couturière une dizaine de livres heures
tous bénévoles pour le département des
yvelines
assez simplement on a appelé on à dire
là on a des blues pour vous est-ce que
vous êtes preneur évidemment ils sont
preneurs il lui manque énormément de
matériel donc
on a pris des contacts comme ça et ça
s'est fait très vite parce que on répond
à un besoin urgent ont nagé le
territoire qui découpent le tissu nous
confectionne des kits prête à courre le
livre à différentes plates formes
logistiques donc dans les yvelines
il y en a deux et ensuite des livreurs
des bénévoles viennent chercher les kits
les apporte chez les bénévoles
couturière et nous ramène les blues
constitué et ensuite on les remet aux
hôpitaux distribution mais alimentaire a
cette fois ci depuis deux jours la
fédération nationale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles et la société
d'autoroute de vinci offre des produits
frais les bénéficiaires les conducteurs
de poids lourds
le mercredi 29 avril et ce jeudi 30
avril ce sont 100 paniers qui ont été
distribués une initiative possible grâce
à la signature d'un partenariat le 27
février dernier au salon de
l'agriculture
tous les ans pour la fête du travail du
1er mai le muguet fait son apparition en
cette de confinement les nombreux points
de vente ont fermé et les ventes à la
sauvette ont été interdites par le
ministre de l'agriculture
didier guillaume seuls les supermarchés
les producteurs pourront proposer le
brin de muguet mathilde de 2 min
cette année il n'y aura pas de vente de
muguet sur la voie publique mais les
fleuristes pourront néanmoins vendre les
clochettes du mois de mai devant leur
magasin au supermarché à guyancourt
quelques bras ont été installés à
l'entrée pour les intéressés avec tout
ce qui se passe là heureusement mois par
pedro ce jeu pour faire part en acheter
c'est des choses qu'on y pense quand
même
après voilà tout dépend de ce qui se
passe et tout ce qui en bon tout ça sent
bon bah c'est vrai que souvent comment
on voit du monde ça fait plaisir
d'offrir donc wallonne cette fois ça
risque de pas être pour offrir ça arrive
d'être pour soi commandez avant le
confinement
le co gérant du magasin installé son
stand de muguet ne sachant pas si les
clients ils trouveront un quelconque
engouement un supermarché on doit ce
qu'on se doit de proposer tout donc le
muguet fait partie des incontournables
en magasin l'idée c'est pas d'en faire
une quantité absolue mais c'est que les
gens on trouve tout ce qu'il faut dans
notre magasin comme et du textile et
cetera et cetera ou
ou à la fête des morts on du
chrysanthème on essaye d'être de tenir
la saison et les grandes fêtes c'est une
vente traditionnels pour le parti
communiste français qui chaque année
pour le 1er mai près par les brins de
muguet symbolisant la lutte des
travailleurs
aucune commande n'a été fait pour
respecter les consignes du confinement
néanmoins une vente sera bien organisé
mais pour recevoir du muguet virtuel
qu'on a organisé une man une vente de
muguet virtuel on a un visuel qui va
être adressée avec des courriels des
relances téléphoniques auprès de nos
camarades auprès de nos sympathisants
auprès des gens qui sont proches de nous
cette vente du muguet nous amener à
engager des frais importants parce que
déjà le média faut l'acheter donc ça on
ne leur a pas donc c'est à la fin qu'on
verra si on a eu moins de recettes ce
que l'année passée si on en a eu
pratiquement autant ou si on a davantage
il faudra attendre pour savoir si cette
année les bénéfices de la vente du
muguet virtuel ont été plus efficace que
la vente habituels
les fleuristes ont obtenu in extremis
l'autorisation de la vente de muguet
c'est la fédération française des
artisans fleuristes qui en a fait
l'annoncé en fin d'après midi les
professionnels proposeront donc des
bruns et des bouquets mais seulement en
extérieur et devant leurs boutiques
c'est un secteur très impacté par la
crise sanitaire du coc u19 la
construction et les travaux publics les
entreprises s'organisent et reprennent
leurs activités tout en assurant la
sécurité des salariés et des clients
reportage avec la société blanchard
basée à saint cyr l'école nicolas landry
et patrick et jacques de dixmude
peinture et pose de parquet dans cet
appartement un chantier de reprise pour
khaled salariés au sein de cette société
spécialisée dans le revêtement en arrêt
depuis le 17 mars l'entreprise a relancé
son activité depuis le lundi 27 avril
on a deux au lot de ce qu'il faut qu'on
comme l'adema et jl entre avant et
dispense un internaute régner entre les
deux réorganisations du planning
replanification de chantier prévue
ultérieurement et équipements sanitaires
pour ses salariés le dirigeant de cette
entreprise du bâtiment à préparer la
reprise
on a repris des chantiers qu'on avait
laissé un peu en stand by
d'autres pas parce qu'on n'a pas
l'accord de nos clients pour pouvoir les
reprendre ces chantiers là tant que la
date de déconfinement est pas prononcée
en l'occurrence on a on doit compter sur
la bonne volonté de nos clients et de
nos salariés aussi c'était important
pour des questions de trésorerie ni plus
ni moins parce que ça devenait compliqué
pour nous à gérer même si on a essayé de
bénéficier des dispositifs de l'état on
a on avait une trésorerie qui nous
permettait quand on allait quand on a su
qu'on allait devoir fermer on avait une
trésorerie qui nous permettait grosso
modo de tenir un mois un peu plus d'un
mois
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire sa
société a obtenu le chômage partiel pour
ses salariés et bénéficier d'un prêt
garanti par l'état pour préparer la
reprise julien blanchard a organisé une
réunion avec ses 15 l employé l'objet de
la réunion d'hier c'était de de les
former entre guillemets les sensibiliser
sur les gestes barrières et la sécurité
qui va falloir mettre encore plus en
oeuvre que d'habitude sur les chantiers
à venir
actuellement 40 % de son effectif a
repris une activité tous les
collaborateurs devraient revenir au
travail à partir du 11 mai entreprise
toujours on s'intéresse maintenant aux
start-up beaucoup d'entre elles sont
aujourd'hui en très grandes difficultés
liées à leur modèle économique fait
notamment de levée de fonds
on fait le point avec hervé mation
fondateur de 6 kg au et créateur d'une
cabine bien-être
elles vont très très mal elles vont très
très mal puisque on a à ce jour perdu
près de 20% déjà des start up qui qui
sont ou en train de déposer le bilan
ou qui sont en train d'arrêter
totalement leurs projets
parce qu'elle en fait elle ne bénéficie
pas ne peuvent pas bénéficier des
mesures qui ont été mis en place par le
gouvernement
et pour cause parce que en fait les
start up aujourd'hui ne sont pas des
entreprises normales sont elles ont un
statut des salles est soudé ça mais dans
leur fonctionnement elles ne
fonctionnent pas normalement il faut
savoir en fait qu'aujourd'hui l'impact
négatif sur les start-up les 80% 80% des
start up qui ont été impactés par cette
par cette crise
il ya deux milliards d'euros qui ont été
libérés par le gouvernement pour les
start up
si vous voulez 7,7 cet argent qui a été
libéré par l'état est soumis à une règle
et une loi qui est une loi européenne de
2014 qu'il dit en fait que ces
subventions ne peuvent aller à des
entreprises qui sont en difficulté
financière ou en soldes négatifs
or il faut savoir une chose c'est que la
plupart des start up dans l'eure dans
leur première année dans les trois à
cinq premières années elles ne feront à
nous gênait repas de chiffre d'affaires
elles sont totalement toujours en
dépenses pour la simple et bonne raison
c'est que avant de générer du chiffre
d'affaires il faut qu'elles créent leurs
produits
or nous on a on a on a vraiment la
triple peine
déjà on n'a pas de chance parce que on
devait commencer à faire du chiffre
d'affaires pour une fois on allait
commencer à faire du chiffre d'affaires
le jour où le premier ministre a a
interdit les événements depuis 200
personnes
on était on était remorque chargée on
était sur la route en train de partir
pour le circuit du mans pour une grosse
manifestation pour porsche c'était notre
première manifestation et derrière on
devait enchaîner avec des manifestations
comme les 24 heures du mans moto les 24
heures du mans auto pas tout un tas de
choses qui allaient pouvoir me faire
entrer de l'argent
bon bah ça forcément avec le avec la
crise tout est tombé mais au-delà de ça
on était en pleine levée de fonds donc
du coup va toutes les levées de fonds il
faut savoir en fait que toutes les
levées de fonds se sont arrêtés nous on
a essayé de rebondir et on va proposer
en fait on propose à chaque personne on
cherche dix mille personnes sur 67
millions on devrait y arriver quand même
j'espère dix mille personnes en capacité
de places et je dis bien placé c'est pas
un don c'est placer de l'argent 50 euros
50 euros dix mille personnes
si on arrive à trouver dix mille
personnes qui place 50 euros et bien on
chauffe le projet elle les messages de
soutien continuent à se multiplier pour
remercier les équipes soignantes et les
personnes touchées par la maladie avec
nous en plateau mathilde de 2min
journalistes de la rédaction bonsoir ont
besoin une chanteuse yvelinoise a voulu
mettre sa pierre à l'édifice et elle est
notre invité est wee cc yatera bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes chanteuse dans les
yvelines et vous avez récemment fait une
reprise de la chanson je ne vous oublie
pas de céline dion en l'adaptant pour
les personnes qui exercent des métiers
et qui les place en première ligne face
au chaos coronavirus comment vous est
venue l'idée
alors
je pense que la volonté première a été
un petit peu comme tous les artistes de
faire savoir aux acteurs du quotidien et
surtout principalement à nos soignants
qu'on pense à eux et et que la situation
très particulière fait que nos actions
sont limitées mais en tant qu'artiste
j'ai j'ai eu cette volonté de leur
signifier qu'on pense à eux tout
simplement
donc on vous oublie pas c'est le nom de
votre cover comment vous avez écrit des
paroles alors les paroles m'ont été
inspirées par le contexte actuel et de
je ne vous oublie pas c'est devenu on ne
vous oublie pas avec cette volonté de
faire apparaître des familles également
confiné parce que j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir collaborer avec mon ami de
toujours sortir avec un grand musicien
au grand coeur qui a réinterprété du
coup le la musique et de là nous est
venue donc l'idée assisté de ma famille
de réaliser un clip est de faire
collaborer
plusieurs familles confiné alors on ne
s'attendait pas à recevoir autant de
manifestations autant de vidéos
lorsqu'on a fait l'appel sur les réseaux
et c'est vrai que paradoxalement ce
confinement nous a beaucoup rapprochés
je me suis aussi appuyé sur sur des sur
des personnes précieuse donc notamment à
liste marque qui est une photographe qui
a réalisé récemment toute une série de
photos qu'elle a intitulé les jocondes
où elle a pris des portraits de
deux femmes principalement soignantes et
donc du coup ça a considérablement
enrichi enrichi ce clip il ya eu
également l'intervention importante d'un
réalisateur qui s'appelle le grand qui
en très peu de temps a très vite compris
ce projet là et qui nous a donné son
concours précieux pour réaliser avec un
grand professionnalisme
cette fin ce clip c'est un bon sens bien
vous de remercier à votre façon les
personnes qui sont en première ligne
mais bien évidemment ces mêmes ces mêmes
prioritaires gens j'ai envie de dire
parce que aujourd'hui les personnes qui
maintienne notre niveau de vie sont ceux
qu'on ne voit pas je pense notamment aux
éboueurs ou aux commerçants pour qu'on a
l'habitude quand même de devoir quand on
va faire nos courses mais il ya aussi
également le personnel soignant lui est
au coeur de tout est qui et qui permet
de sauver des vies bon an mal an et on
se doit d'y penser donc il ya cette
manifestation la importante à 20 heures
tous les soirs où plusieurs personnes
manifestent ce soutien ça je trouve que
c'est très important qu'on a tous qu'on
a tous à un devoir en ce sens est en
tout cas savoir qu'on est là merci sert
l'intérêt d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et on va vous remercier à un
extrait avant de passer
on ne vous oubliera
boudra l'état
pour nos vies pour que ces crises à
venir
merci martin c'est avec un autre clip
qu'on va se quitter
cette fois il aurait dû se produire le
28 avril dernier sur la scène du cabaret
du bout des prêts mais bien sûr
l'actualité en a décidé autrement
les 77 enfants de l'école de la celle
des bandes ont tout de même fait parler
leur fibre artistique
ils ont ainsi réalisé un clip sur la
direction de tony bastion le responsable
du cabaret et je vous propose de le
découvrir tout de suite je vous souhaite
une très belle soirée sur notre antenne
et surtout n'oubliez pas rester chez
vous prenez soin de vous
[Musique]
ne rien faire
schmoll
pour les soignants les deux
et demain peu
on chante on sait pas
les échéances
[Musique]
il